Ja Chico gefällt das auch nicht Wenn Chico Windows Server sieht ist er gleich
wieder weg Windows Server
Ja wir müssen uns das heute wirklich mal geben warum weiß ich auch nicht so genau
angeblich hat der Microsoft die letzten Jahre so viel gemacht dass das jetzt viel viel besser
ist ich mein Docker läuft unter Windows Hyper-V ist angeblich ganz gut WSL 2 und was nicht
alles gibt angeblich hat Windows jetzt doch so gar nicht SSH Server glaube ich ja also weiß
man ja nicht was da los ist. Müssen wir wieder ausprobieren aber ich kann euch gleich sagen
wahrscheinlich werde ich zwischendurch ganz schön flamen wieder gegen Windows. Ich mein man könnte
natürlich ganz big brain machen Windows installieren und dann darauf WSL installieren und alles in
Linux machen oder aber Hyper-V installieren und alles in der Ubuntu-VM machen. Ich hoffe du nimmst
auch die Version ohne Desktop. Also was ist mit ohne Desktop gemeint? Ich habe keine Ahnung davon
also wenn ohne Desktop gemeint ist halt ohne irgendwelche hier 3D und Transparenz und so ja
dann dann bin ich dabei aber ansonsten habe ich keine Ahnung wie man Windows Server bedient
ohne hier irgendwie ein bisschen rumklicken. Keine Ahnung wir probieren das jetzt mal aus ob man das
überhaupt runterladen kann richtig. Try Windows Server now. On Azure. Ne ne ne ne. On Azure geht
da grad nicht. Free Trial das klingt doch schon mal gut. Exzellent. Exzellent klingt das. ISO wie
da da. Microsoft ist auch lustig oder? Bei Windows 10 machen sie einen riesen Akt dass man keine ISO
runterladen darf und beim Server ist es wird direkt angeboten sogar als Virtual Disk Image.
Übrigens bei der Gelegenheit zeige ich immer ganz gerne den Trick für die Windows 10 ISO weil es
irgendwie jedes mal wenn ich das im Stream zeige sind die Leute überrascht wie einfach das doch
geht. Also sprich wenn ihr euch den Windows 10 Update runterladen wollt dann geht das nicht.
Da kannst du immer nur sagen Tool jetzt herunterladen, aktualisieren, bla, sonst was.
Sobald man aber hier auf Inspect geht und den Mobile Modus einschaltet dann sollte es eigentlich
funktionieren. Bin ich auf der falschen Seite geht das nicht mehr. Ich habe auf jetzt aktualisieren
geklickt. Okay und jetzt passiert nichts. Achso wow wow wow wow wow wow. Windows ist ja gut.
Alles gut Windows alles gut. Reload, ja ja ihr habt recht aber erstmal den ganzen Scheiß wieder
weg machen ja. Genau also sprich wenn man jetzt hier auf Inspect geht und in die Mobile Ansicht
und dann reloadet man die Seite und zack kann man Windows 10 ISOs runterladen. Richtig big brain.
Habt ihr gesehen funktioniert jetzt. Wenn man es normal aufmacht ohne mobile Seite geht es nicht.
Macht man es mit mobile Seite auf reloaded kann man hier auswählen Windows 10 ISO download alles
gut. Wollen wir aber nicht wir wollen die Windows Server 2019 ISO downloaden. 180 Tage. Na ob das mal
reicht. Ich werde es eh nach dem Stream wieder runterschmeißen was soll ich damit. Ein Noob kann
mit einer ISO nichts anfangen. Das ist mir egal ob da ein Noob damit was anfangen kann oder nicht.
Ich kann aber mit dem ISO was anfangen. Deswegen geht es mir immer auf den Keks dass sie nicht
einfach direkt einen ISO download anbieten. Und warum das mit dem mobile Ansicht geht ist ganz
einfach. Leute die nicht von Windows auf drauf gehen die sollen natürlich den ISO download
angeboten kriegen. Weil Microsoft vielleicht hofft ah die installieren den Windows. Keine Ahnung.
Ok please select. Also ISO wollen wir haben. First name KekW. Last name größer nein kleiner
kleiner Lulve. Company name cute chat. Company size ja so meistens zumindest.
Good company. Das ist das Gegenteil zu bad company. Job title. Hey wir sind CEO. Wie
einfach nur. Warum ich bin hier der head of. 10 minute mail. Das ist die falsche 10 minute
mail. Das ist die richtige 10 minute mail. Ok excellent. Work phone number 069 000. Was
auch immer. Germany. No continue. Lulve geht nicht. Continue. Select one. Englisch wir können
es auch auf Chinesisch runterladen. Englisch download. Alles klar 1776 37 37 190 906 2324
3.5. Release SVC. Refresh Server. IWAL X64 FRE EN US 1 ISO. Alles klar. Jetzt weiß ich
Bescheid. Gut dass sie das so genannt haben. Ohne den Namen wäre ich überhaupt nicht in
der Lage gewesen das zu installieren und geschweige denn runterzuladen. Yes ex exquisite Name. Big
brain file names. Warum habe ich eigentlich die ganzen Kram hier nur auf. Teff. Ok das
sind die Videos die wir noch übrig haben vom Sondag oder so. Bookmark. Session. Nicht
new folder. Keine Ahnung. Letzte. So und jetzt haben wir hier Session. Letzte ist der ganze
Kram drin. Ok das liegt wahnsinnig geschwind runter. Das kapiert nur Windows Admins. Ja
wahrscheinlich. Noch nicht mal die. Also wenn ich mir so unsere Windows Admins angucke
da habe ich nicht so wirklich das Vertrauen drin dass da das einer von kapiert. Ich frage
mich eh manchmal was Windows Admins den ganzen Tag so machen. Also außer vielleicht irgendwelche
Microsoft Knowledge Base Einträge sich angucken. Also ich persönlich das kann natürlich auch
täuschen ja habe den Eindruck dass Windows Admins nicht unbedingt so am oberen Spektrum
der Erkenntnis Skala stehen. Also sprich wenn du Leute wenn du mal unten welche hast die
gar keine Ahnung haben und oben die übelsten Pros was IT Sachen angeht dann sind Windows
Admins eher so in der Mitte. Die meisten. Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel PC lustig.
Naja und Linux Leute würde ich sagen die sind im oberen Drittel. Die meisten. Ausnahmen
bestätigen auch da die Regel. Wir haben bei uns teilweise Leute am Start die sich eigentlich
Bedienungs auskennen sollten wo dir denkst was ist mit denen los. Ich habe es dir letztens
erzählt der eine der engen Änderungen am L System gemacht hat und mit dem der dann
irgendwelche kaputten Git commits und ach was auch immer da gibt es auch unfähige Leute
gibt es überall ja. Ruby ne der ist nicht mehr da der Kommentator der Ruby Typ ist nicht
mehr da der war aber egal. Während das runter während das runter läuft kann ich es ja gerade
noch mal erzählen für alle die es da nicht mitgekriegt haben. Beim Kommentator hat es
das anscheinend eingebrannt wir hatten mal einen externen Experten am Start der wurde
Big Brain mäßig halt eingekauft für ZFS für Solaris und ZFS haben sie den eingekauft
bei uns und als der dann angefangen hat quasi so eins zwei Monate später nachdem sie jemand
gesucht haben haben sie ihm gesagt ja jetzt machen wir doch kein Solaris ZFS und da war
er aber schon da und dann musste er da musste er in ein halbes Jahr oder ein dreiviertel Jahr
war er da musste der was anderes machen und da hat er überhaupt keinen Bock drauf gehabt
und er ist von Woche zu Woche immer mehr durchgedreht der Typ und ZFS das Fallsystem ja auf Solaris
also auf dem guten Oracle Geschiss da und der ist von Woche zu Woche immer weiter durchgedreht
da hatte den übelsten Knall der Typ der hat es halt irgendwann geschafft dass der seine
seinen Linux Desktop hat er so eingerichtet dass wenn er mit dem wenn er mit dem Maus mit
dem Mauszeiger an Bildschirmrand gekommen ist ich glaube das hat er gemacht dass er nicht
einschläft dabei hat sein PC Speaker gesummt also es lief dann ab und zu so der ist dann mit dem
Maus mit der Maus an der Rand gekommen vom Bildschirm und hat es dann gemacht das PC Speaker hat
dann gesummt ich wusste gar nicht wie man sowas einstellt überhaupt die bescheuertste Extension die
ich je gesehen habe naja zumindest der ist wie gesagt der ist immer der ist immer weiter durchgedreht
der ist immer weiter durchgedreht mit der Zeit und wir hatten damals relativ viel was in Ruby
programmiert war und dann hat er dann immer angefangen zwischendurch vor sich hin zu zu
reden Ruby der ist immer weiter durchgedreht so irgendwann lief das dann so irgendwann lief
das dann so dann ist er mit dem Mauszeiger gegen den Bildschirmrand gekommen also hat
ein Known Desktop und er hat es auf dem Known Desktop geschrieben er wollte irgendwie nicht
zugeben dass er das selbst konfiguriert hat das muss er selbst konfiguriert haben anders ist es
gar nicht möglich ja und da ist er mit dem Bildschirm Zeiger mit dem Maus Zeiger an den
Bildschirmrand gekommen hat er PC Speaker hat dann gesummt und dann hat er gesagt also
hat er gesagt der scheiß Known Ruby der ist komplett abgedrehter Typ mit der Zeit
gut nach dem dreiviertel Jahr war er dann wieder weg da konnte er wahrscheinlich irgendwo anders
dann wirklich Solaris und ZFS machen aber der ist der ist immer weiter dem Wahnsinn verfallen
ja gut wenn du auch eingekauft wirst für ein Thema was dich interessiert und dann kommst du
hin und kriegst gesagt ey ne wir machen jetzt was ganz was anderes da kannst du schon ein
bisschen durchdrehen im Kopf so ist der Download jetzt fertig ja was hier Tommy fragt hey Max ich
programmiere schon ziemlich lange und es liegt mir eher im Gefühl als dass ich eine rationale
Begründung dafür habe ob ich Referenz oder Value Types benutzt ach du groß jetzt hier kommt Big
Brain Talk Expanding habe ich das hier überhaupt hier Expanding Brain kommt jetzt hier aber der
Talk wird jetzt richtig Big Brain der reicht schon der reicht schon der 5 Kopf nicht mehr
okay ob ich Referenz oder Value Types benutzen sollte mir sind die Unterschiede deutlich klar
mit dem aber es gibt irgendwie eine Forstfolie eigentlich so scheiße du fragst mich jetzt hier
Dinger nein nein Morpheus damit fangen wir jetzt nicht an ja also eine fällt mir ein wenn du die
vergleichen willst ob die gleich sind weil Value Types ist standardmäßig sind die gleich wenn der
Inhalt gleich ist Reference Types nicht also wenn du wenn du überprüfen willst ob was ich mein das
ist nicht so dass das nicht mit Reference Types auch funktionieren würde du kannst einfach Equals
da überschreiben funktioniert aber standardmäßig würde ich sagen ey wenn ich über wenn ich wenn
ich überprüfen will ob der Inhalt gleich ist dann würden sich vielleicht Value Types eher anbieten
weil da ist es halt einfach standardmäßig so oder aber wenn man kopieren will ohne das original zu
verändern dann auch Value Types ansonsten keine ahnung also ich würde das auch eher nachgefühlt
wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss ich verwende eigentlich fast nie Value Types ich verwende
eigentlich zu 99,9% einfach Class und Class ist Reference und ich mach mir da eigentlich gesagt
auch selten Gedanken drüber puh also ja gut in C++ ihr wisst ich bin ja der wahnsinnig große
C++ Fan was das angeht unter C++ sagt jetzt ja dass das die C++ Pros sagen jetzt ja also
da meine meine mit denen ich ganz dicke bin ne also die C++ Profis sagen ja man soll gar
keine Pointer mehr verwenden soll also gar keine also keine richtigen Pointer mehr hier sondern
man soll nur noch Smartpoint ne ne ne wie heißt das wie heißt das unter C++ heißt das nicht
Smartpoint ne wie heißt denn das jetzt Unique Pointer und Shared Pointer und das ist Smartpointer
ich glaube das sind Smartpointer und unter C++ soll man nur noch Smartshared Poin- Unique ja
sind das nicht Smartpointer Smart Pointer oh ne das ist was anderes what the f- doch doch
genau das hier meine ich also C++ Leute sagen jetzt ja man soll gar keinen normalen Pointer
mehr verwenden sondern nur diese big brain Pointer die man nicht lesen kann also die da
C++ Leute haben ja den Hang dazu alles mögliches kryptisch zu machen und deswegen sagen die
ja hier soll man machen bei C++ finde ich es eigentlich relativ einfach sobald man das
woanders braucht als in der lokal in der Funktion dann musst du ja nen Pointer verwenden bleibt
dir gar nichts anderes übrig großartig einziger Unterschied ist einziger Unterschied ist ja ich
weiß also was auch geht ist wenn man wenn man Funktionen aufruft dann kann ich das Ding
oben nicht als Pointer Decklager in kein Referenz übergeben das funktioniert auch aber letztendlich
in C++ finde ich ist es einfacher weil sobald man es nicht lokal in der Funktion verwendet
muss es nen Pointer sein und hier muss man sich halt nicht ums aufräumen kümmern also
Funktion lokal das übergreifen mehr oder weniger immer das du kannst ja immer kopieren oder mit
uns ja das kann man machen aber das ist wozu soll ich mehr kopieren als ich das br was ist
denn cbr ist das cbr cbr c++ also call by reference verstehe exzellent ganz big brain
abkürzung heute punkt h alles klar nein ich brauche gar nichts in c++ aus das muss sein c++
kam ja kann man mich sonst vor jep kann mich c++ ok der download ist fertig oder ich bin schon
wieder da exzellent worauf willst du das install ich will es mir einfach mal angucken also ich
habe mir überlegt was wir machen ist folgendes die habe ich gerade schluck auf das ja also was
ich mir überlegt habe ist folgendes wir installieren uns 2019 server 2019 dann gucken wir mal wie
remote access funktioniert angeblich kann das ja mittlerweile ssh mal schauen mal schauen
mal keine ahnung habe ich nicht ausprobiert müssen wir mal schauen dann gucken wir wie
man da eine statische html seite aus dem kann dann gucken wir wie man da mittlerweile packages
nach installiert so ob man da zum beispiel einfach den engine x nach installieren kann
wahrscheinlich nicht renax kommt das kommt manchmal vor jetzt hier wir waren schon mindestens
zwei leute drin die ich von der arbeit kenne das ist wahrscheinlich habt ihr das nicht
so mitgekriegt aber kommt manchmal vor so dann gucken wir mal wie man da nen file server
macht dann dann will ich mal gucken wie man docker unter windows installiert weil das geht
ja angeblich und ist ganz toll dann gucken ob man hyper wie installiert kriegen und wsl
und so weiter mal schauen mal schauen ja mal gucken wie wir das auf die reihe kriegen
es wird aber es wird aber wahrscheinlich echt eklig werden kann ich jetzt schon sagen
weil windows ist halt pauschal eklig ok also virtual machine custom next next äh nicht
linux hätte auch nicht gedacht dass ich in nächster zeit hier mal wieder umsteigen aber
ist das sound zu laut nö passt da eigentlich ganz gut oder sound zu laut ticken leiser
ticken lauter passt so oder also wenn ich sehe hier ist meine stimme da ist sound und
ähm das ist ja decibel logik also sprich das da ist quasi nur irgendwie nen viertel
so laut wie das da dann weil decibel logik weil scheiß einheit scheiß skala ist ja keine
einheit bisschen lauter können wir machen können wir ein bisschen ticken können wir
natürlich gerade mal kurz zurück machen wo es so schön laut war ja so lassen wir es
jetzt exzellent so also windows jetzt kommen wir ja aus dem windows server 2016 ok 2019
gibt es dann noch gar nicht next äh das ganze installieren wir übrigens auf e vms new folder
äh cacw komm egal wie das ding heißt äh next uevi boot ok äh cpus äh vier stück
mit vier kerne 4096 mb ram sollte erst mal reichen bridge network weil ich will vielleicht
auch von außen drauf zugreifen mal gucken äh was auch immer next ja wenn du das als
ssd machen willst mach ssd virtual disc 60g reichen reich Leute reichen 60g ja bestimmt
bestimmt 63 muss muss reichen wir machen da nichts großartig mit das müssen wir gleich
mal gucken wie groß der windows server nach der installation nach der installation ist
mal gucken mal gucken ob das mal gucken wie groß das ist so next customize hardware äh
ja gut display müssen wir dran lassen drucke mal weg soundcard lassen wir mal dran weil
ich wissen will ob dort auch cortana am anfang rumschwätzt finish ok power on was no i finish
install ja nerv mich ok cd rein settings iso images downloads dieser dateiname macht mich
echt fertig äh wer hat sich das denn ausgedacht war microsoft wieder ok und neustart windows
installieren zack äh ah vielleicht sollte man cd laufwerk einschalten dann gehts dann
gehts auch excellent view stretch oh ne ich war zu langsam jetzt noch mal press any key
kann ich ein nice bekommen so language install englisch time currency setzen wir mal auf
german ost in belgien reden in belgien ja doch teile in was warum kam jetzt nicht germany
germany danach und next install nema ja ja ja das gibt es leider noch nicht als sprache
so was können was können ok was ist der unterschied data center und standard desktop experience
was ist denn da der unterschied dazwischen meinen die mit des options voll voll windows
ne das brauchen wir nicht das brauchen wir nicht ich will ich will also ich brauche
da kein transparenz und hintergrund ich brauche aber halt das normale windows geklicke weil
ich sonst nicht weiß wie man das einrichtet manage with command prompt powershell oh ne
das ne ne das das das geht nicht das da hab ich keine ahnung wie es funktioniert dass
man das desktop experience nennt das klingt schon so fancy irgendwie schon ja ich brauch
auf jeden fall desktop also mit powershell bin ich nicht in der ich weiß ja nicht mal
wie ich das windows admin center überhaupt starte wobei ich würde es ja gerne sehen
wie das das probiere ich jetzt mal aus nema snapshot es geht ja schnell das geht ja schnell
ich probiere mir jetzt einfach mal aus ich will mal wissen wie ein windows ohne grafische
oberfläche aussieht das wird mich jetzt mal interessieren das ist bestimmt gebaited sieht
bestimmt genauso aus nur dass einfach kein desktop geladen wird obwohl alles dabei ist
custom next das installieren geht ja schnell das dauert 5 minuten oder so full experience
eh full experience machen wir danach weil ich kann windows wahrscheinlich nicht managen
gescheit ohne grafische oberfläche ich weiß jetzt schon dass ich mich darüber aufregend
werde wie unnötig kompliziert alles ist man muss ja sagen vieles ist unter linux auch
nicht wirklich intuitiv aber man hat sich dran gewöhnt wahrscheinlich ist es bei windows
admin ist es für windows admins ähnlich zum beispiel unter windows ist es auch total und
intuitiv dass alle programme irgendwie unterschiedliche parameter haben ja mal ist es minus minus
version mal ist es minus groß v mal ist es einfach nur leerzeichen version mal ist es
keine ahnung minus version groß minus version klein also sprich das ist unter linux auch
überhaupt nicht einheitlich was ich aber witzig finde unter windows ist es auch nicht wirklich
einheitlich obwohl es mal eben gut ich meine microsoft kriegt es auf dem desktop ja auch
schon mal nicht hin also warum soll ich diesen server hinkriegen das ging schnell das ging
echt schnell das hat eine minute gedauert den kram zu installieren big brain speed jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt wie das aussieht ohne grafische oberfläche bis jetzt sieht es vollkommen
normal aus nur halt nach windows sogar mauszeiger habe ich schon gesehen wahrscheinlich geht
da einfach powershell fenster auf ja ist ja gerade abgekackt oder ist es normal dass
er sich neu startet kann es sein dass es kaputt ist ah nee moment ernsthaft what the fuck
das ist ohne grafische oberfläche das ist doch nicht ohne grafische oberfläche da wird
einfach kein desktop gestartet es stinkt am allen kratz microsoft ok jetzt mal ernstgemeinte
frage warum sollte ich diese variante überhaupt installieren ich meine die paar gigabyte
festplattenplatz machen sie auch nicht aus oder das ist das wird weder schneller sein
noch sonst was also warum ok user password ok also ok moment ich habe rechts reingeklickt
fack wie kriegt es wieder weg ok ok 123456 123456 unable ah das ist nicht kompliziert
genug verstehe selbst als admin darf ich das nicht ok 123456 underscore 123456 underscore
auch nicht oh jetzt wirds aber big brain 123456 underscore groß a 123456 underscore groß
a ah das geht ok das ist viel sicherer ok ach du scheiße das ist wirklich einfach so
ein komisches cmd ding was passiert dann jetzt wenn man control alt entfernen drückt es
geht ein neues fenster auf und ich kann den task manager aufmachen sogar der task manager
ist dabei das ist doch nicht ohne grafische oberfläche das ist eine ganz normale grafische
oberfläche nur dass kein desktop gestartet wird kann man kann man hier ok ok ok ok ok
run new tasker guck mal ich kann jetzt hier drüber sachen starten dann an die pausen
kann ich nicht weil kein desktop gestartet ist cmd die powershell powershell aha echo
null null was jetzt natürlich richtig big brain wäre wenn ich von hier wsl nachinstallieren
kann und einfach ganz normal das ding verwenden kann wie linux aber das wird nicht funktionieren
ok ich brauche einen grafischen desktop sonst komme ich mach mal explorer nee das gibt
es bestimmt nicht explorer kalk auch nicht ok die haben wirklich die ganzen grafisch
sein also der unterschied ist im prinzip nur dass die grafischen sachen nicht installiert
sind was soll ich probieren abwitz was abwitz witz cpl geht nicht wie konfiguriere ich
das ding eigentlich jetzt wie installiere ich jetzt hier sachen ok sign out switch user
cancel cancel ok wie installiere ich jetzt überhaupt sachen drauf nougat gibt es das
konfig wow das sieht ja aus wie windows 2000 1ks also ich will jetzt als erstes mal den
desktop nachinstallieren wie mache ich das denn ok remote desktop 7 enable less secure
ok habt ihrs gesehen man hat einen kommando zeilen konfigprogramm aber es ploppt immer
noch ein ok fenster auf wo man drauf drücken muss windows logik wie kriege ich jetzt die
ip adresse von dem ding raus mein was interessiert mich dieser komische kackname ich brauche
die ip von dem teil configure remote management network settings da 2.130 alles klar ms tsc
und 130 ist es administrator 1 2 3 4 5 6 underscore a yes high res high res ohne desktop ok grandios
kann man jetzt die auflösung hier hoch stellen font erstmal ein bisschen fetter machen das
ganze so ist das ist das nice es passt natürlich nicht genau drauf das wäre auch sonst so
einfach ok wie wie kriege ich jetzt den desktop wieder drauf weil ihr mein hier kriege ich
ja kriege ich ja absolut anfälle bei und das sage ich als linux mann der den ganzen tag
auf der kommando zeile setzt oder kriege ich zu kriege gibt es zumindest ein schönes gui
für windows konfig in irgendeiner art und weise das kann nur die zukunft sein oh guck
mal guck mal telemetrie settings telemetrie settings habt ihrs gesehen das gibt es sogar
in der windows server ja yes warum muss ich mit der maus zwischendurch klicken was ist
für ein schwachsinn ich habe ich habe den terminal konfig ja aber ich muss zwischendrin
immer noch klicken was bei windows 2019 musst du komplett nach installieren ernsthaft jetzt
ok ich bin ich bin nicht begeistert aber ich habe das auch nichts anderes erwartet chat
ich glaube euch aber ich muss mal kurz wirklich reinstall desktop install desktop experience
ok blablabla können die einfach zum punkt kommen
ok log in als start server manager ok add roles and features wo ist das add roles and
features roles and features
ich glaube ich bin hier gar nicht im richtigen tool drinnen ok ok start server manager from
cmd ok es heißt einfach server manager alles klar server server manager exe ok aber wenn
server manager nicht ohne guis wie mach ich denn da überhaupt was da muss ich die ganzen
powershell sachen kennen oder und gut ok ok ich ich ich bin überzeugt ich muss die desktop
experience nehmen ich bin ich bin überzeugt chat kuchendienst drei monat dankeschön excellent
subscription ich ich resette snapshot mit desktop experience hätte sein können vor allem warum
kann man das nicht nach installieren das ist ja total hängen geblieben warum es ergibt
überhaupt keinen sinn microsoft logik ok also sind wir stehen geblieben standard ok
standard desktop experience next ich hätte nachgucken soll ich den speicherplatz belegt
jetzt auch ja hätte ich machen können jetzt zu spät next ich starte schon mal meine linux
vm hier mit dem ppega board dass ich keine fragen verpasse und ich brauche ja nachher
ich brauche ich muss unbedingt ssh zugang testen weil ich habe irgendwo letztens gelesen
dass man mittlerweile den ssh server installieren kann unter windows das muss ich unbedingt
ausprobieren er darf das vor allem mit was läuft das denn dann cmd in ssh oder oder
was da bin ich mal gespannt drauf so jetzt installiert auch ein bisschen länger aber
geht trotzdem schnell
power shell big brain 5 hat baldrian die frage stellt ich weiß nicht genau was ich
bezieh ist aber die frage stellt sich bei mir nicht weil ich werde mir noch in der
produktiven umgebung einsetzen ich will es mir einfach nur mal angucken damit ich wieder
damit ich wieder weiß warum ich will dass ich mag toxics minus 380 ja komm da geht aber
noch ein bisschen mehr oder also es gibt ein paar sachen das zum beispiel was easy killer
anspricht es gibt ein paar sachen die würde ich tatsächlich mit windows machen also wenn
ich sie machen müsste also active directory geduld ist halt mit samba scheiße muss man
auch mal sagen wenn ich was gibt es dann sonst noch schönes wenn ich windows client management
deployment was auch immer machen muss also alles was irgendwie mit ad und windows management
zu tun klar das würde ich mit windows machen terminal remote terminal server mit mit rdp
mit dieser neuen rdp extension würde ich auch logischerweise mit windows machen ach so warum
man nicht die desktop xp das stimmt das ist richtig ich finde es trotzdem blöd dass man
sie nicht nach installieren kann ich meine er spricht warum nicht ich meine ich kann
ja beispielsweise unter irgendeinem sagen wir irgendwie ich habe einen ubuntu server
da kann ich auch einfach das paket für desktop installieren dann schicken wir mal ein desktop
drauf klox hd aiya ja aber sowas von
und ansonsten wo würde ich den noch ganz ehrlich wo würde ich noch windows einsetzen
vielleicht wenn ich auch cortana cortana light vielleicht wenn ich in game stream firma wäre
weil ich spiele nur unter unter windows laufen wobei ja auch da stadia lief ja auch unter
lief stadia unter linux oder bsd ich glaube stadia lief unter linux zum größten teil
die playstation hat bsd hat free bsd als kernel oder minimal betriebssystem drauf ok pass
mal gucken ob ich jetzt hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 machen darf oder ob das auch die night wird
finish ok da war wir das gleich 1 2 3 4 5 6 underscore a 1 2 3 4 5 6 underscore a liegt
gleich klipp machen ich komme da auch nicht mehr rein mal das video gesehen wo fail overflow
linux auf der ps4 zum laufen bekommen hat nee aber ich habe ein paar videos dazu gesehen
man kann den username von admin nicht ändern ja jetzt am anfang nicht vielleicht später
schon aber ich könnte mir vorstellen das administrator so ein ding ist ok fuck es sieht
wirklich aus wie windows 10 aber nur reinklicken reinklicken geht nicht mehr reinklicken geht
nicht mehr
jetzt wollen sie es aber echt wissen da ist auch der server manager ok jetzt ok das
ist das ist genau das was ich von windows server erwartet habe nach der installation
erstmal 5 pop ups und internet explorer den habe ich auch erwartet also do you want to
allow your pc to be discover yes windows admin center brings together ok es ist internet
explorer guck mal die blocken sich sogar selbst die blocken sich sogar selbst du kannst
ihn selbst nicht mal aufmachen geh weg geh weg weiche weiche ok was wollen die von mir
windows admin center ist ein lokal bereitgestellte browser basierter ok elektron verstehe laden
sie windows admin center aus dem microsoft evolutions ok mein mein ich soll admin center
aus dem evaluation center runterladen mache ich wie geht denn das ok schon mal nicht schon
mal nicht mit internet explorer ok wie krieg ich einen ordentlichen browser das läuft
hier gar nicht mehr wie krieg ich denn ok chrome chrome chrome ok nein nein ich will
chrome nicht auf deutsch was ist das ich will ich will chrome auf englisch haben chrome
nicht beta chrome englisch en nein aha ja was ist das eigentlich von kack kann das mal
weggehen wie kriege ich da jetzt chrome drauf ok ok wir probieren das mal mit mir aus port
ich habe so keinen plan davon ok edge kann man edge ist edge da nein wie kriege ich da
ok ok wie krieg ich da du darfst nichts downloaden ja ich merks ich hab ne idee ich hab ne idee
chip wir laden uns von chip alter wind aha ich krieg anfälle chrome 14 spit download
excellent ja chrome download jawoll naja naja alles gut alles gut bitte aktiv ok ok das
ist die erste hürde wie krieg ich den gescheiten web browser drauf ich muss ja einen gescheiten
web browser drauf kriegen dass dass ich mir das windows admin das admin center angucken
kann ok ok ich muss ich hab ne idee ich hab ne idee was unter internet option ok internet
option ne ne wir machen das anders ich hab ich hab big brain big brain 360 die idee wir
installieren jetzt erstmal forever tools installieren forever tools und wenn ich forever tools
installiert hab dann copy paste ich mir ne chrome exe von meinem host drauf so so machen
wir das jetzt hoffentlich hoffentlich kann man forever tools installieren weiter ok da
muss ich das stretching ausmachen sonst packt er rum standard installieren excellent excellent
server manager für ee sicherheitseinstellung nein nein nein wir machen keine ee sicherheitseinstellung
ee weg so yes start neu hat er stand da grad stopping telemetrie services warum warum
laufen auf meinem server überhaupt telemetrie services kann man das nicht mal auf den server
schalten so send control alt entfernen 1 2 3 fels underscore a so und jetzt schalten
wir er die ne ja ja ja lass es mal auf lass mal auf lass mal auf alles gut lass lass auf
so guck ich mir gleich an so und jetzt moment download chrome ja ich weiß dass ich schon
chrome hab ich weiß dass ich schon ich will chrome ich will chrome nochmal nochmal laden
excellent easy easy outplayed
ha ha wieso ist eigentlich auf dem server internet explorer und nicht edge drauf eine
exellente frage kann man kann man edge wenigstens nach installieren remove vielleicht vielleicht
kann man irgendwie edge da drüber aktivieren weil microsoft nicht will dass man surft ja
deswegen haben sie internet explorer drauf gemacht er geht schon gar nicht mehr das problem
ist ja ohne paket manager ist es halt naja optional features was auch immer also ich
meine ich brauche einen browser dass ich mir das hier angucken kann so google chrome jawoll
auf geht's so jetzt kann ich mir endlich das admin center angucken also was wollt ihr
von mir download admin center mache ich continue noch einmal ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
jetzt eingeben kann jetzt ok 0 continue 0 continue 069 000 continue next sollte einem
das wort evaluation nicht angst machen auf ein produkt hier eigentlich schon ja so
Oh, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was da jetzt so geil dran ist, ja jawoll, äh bei der Suche
nach meiner, was, das macht er doch eh schon oder, warum muss ich das eben installation
vom admin center auswählen, was auch immer, was?
gateway server, what the fuck, ich hab keine Ahnung was der von mir will, winrm, was ist
winrm, gateway endpoint, ok Moment, also Microsoft hat doch vorher gesagt, das ist eine lokale
browser Anwendung, was will der jetzt von mir, ach windows remote management ist das, aha
windows admin center, ja weiter, 4 für 3, ach so meinen die das mit lokaler web Anwendung,
ich meine gar kein elektronen Zeug, verstehe, du installierst dir gerade einen webserver,
wahrscheinlich ja, sieht so aus, mal gucken was er macht, das admin center hat auf einem
server nichts zu suchen, aber warum schlägt der mir das denn vor, dass ich das installieren
soll, was auch immer, wir installieren das jetzt mal und gucken was das ist, öffnen
sie diese url in einem browser auf einem pc, nein doch doch nicht im internet explorer,
alter nicht im internet explorer, ok, administrator, nein, administrator, 356, underscore a, save,
das admin center, da ist es, fertig stellen, big brain admin center, ok, winrm, so, extensions,
oh jetzt wirds aber richtig big brain hier, update für das azure security center, natürlich
immer update, update, nicht dass ich das azure security center brauche, ist das so eine art,
also es sieht nicht so aus ja, aber es sieht ein bisschen aus wie die microsoft account
settings und das azure frontend, das kind quasi aus microsoft account settings und azure
frontend, das was ich hier sehe, hier oben gibt es eine powershell scripts, kann man eine
konsole aufmachen, nee, man kann nur vorgefertigtes scripts, das da oben gebatet, das tut so als
wäre es eine konsole, ist aber gar keine konsole, warum ist da ein internet explorer drauf,
weil das der einzige browser ist, der standardmäßig installiert ist, remote powershell, so, das
erste was wir jetzt mal machen noch ist rdp einschalten, wie schalte ich rdp ein, ok,
one figure this local server, install windows update, ah wie macht man eigentlich windows
updates hier drüber, auch so, update, some settings are managed by your organization,
echt ich bin meine organisation, ok wie macht man rdp an, manage tools, wobei wir haben doch
schon vorhin gelernt wie man das macht, sconfig, configure remote management, enable remote
management, ha, big brain, muss 2-3 mal zoomen bis alle, wow, ok wo steht hier remote management,
ich seh es, ach hier da, jetzt ist remote management enabled und desktop is disabled, was, remote
desktop firewall exceptions, ja, nein alles darf sich connecten, ok und jetzt kann ich
da drauf, ok, ausprobieren, oho, 123456, ah, 123456, underscore a, remember me, ok,
neues zertifikat, alles klar, da sind wir, it's magic, oh, moment, diese komischen windows
gesten gehen auch unter rdp, sehe ich das richtig, big brain kommt nicht von alleine,
gut, das können wir wieder ausmachen, das brauchen wir nicht, gut, jetzt kann ich zu
den eigentlichen Sachen mal übergehen, die ich ausprobieren wollte, zum beispiel wollte
ich den ssh server installieren, ssh, nee, add, nee das war's anderes, connect to the
windows account, continue, was, nein, what the f, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Da gibt es jetzt links die Remote-Power-Shell, ah ne, das ist Remote-Desktop, Moment ich
kann das Remote-Desktop in meinem Remote-Desktop aufmachen? Moment geht das? Was? We are not
valid. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, underscore A. Natürlich sind die valid. Das erinnert mich irgendwie
an Yo-Dog. I put RDP in your RDP, I can RDP while RDP. So kann man hier suchen, also SSH.
Hallo, search, ok. Ach so meinen die das mit. Ok, add. SSH, wie installiere ich hier ein
SSH drauf? Rolls. Das ist schon an? Wirklich? Wie läuft's mit de Vibers? Du meinst mit den
Hockengrills? Fuck-Server. Ok, also ihr sagt, der ist schon drauf. Das können wir ja mal
ausprobieren, ob der schon drauf ist. Und zwar, ah ne, da gehen wir nicht hin. Wir gehen auf
unsere Niedungskiste, SSH, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 3, 0. Nein, der ist nicht drauf, der SSH
also aber. Gebaided, chat. Gebaided. Ach ne, Firewall-Regeln sind nicht erlaubt, kann das
sein? Firewall. Firewall-Network, schalt mal einfach aus. Willst du mal Kinder haben eigentlich?
Nein, auf keinen Fall. Private Network Active, mal schalte das einfach aus. Windows Defender
Firewall, aus. Weg, weg damit. Ach guck mal, es pinkt da auch. Ok, jetzt. Ne, gebaided,
siste Leute, kein SSH drauf. Warum gibt es hier oben eigentlich kein Suchknopf? SSH.
Wie geht das, dass er Better Twitch Demotes in deinem Stream-Chat anzeigt? Das macht das
automatisch. Wie kriege ich hier einen SSH-Server installiert, Leute? Seht ihr das irgendwo?
Demote-System. Fuck-Server. Ok, Moment, Moment. Windows 2019 install SSH-Server. Optional
Features. Aha. Apps. Apps and Features. Also ich hab ja Mitleid mit jedem, der den Kram
administrieren muss ohne die Oberfläche. Apps and Features. Manage Optional Features. Add
Feature. Äh, kann man jetzt hier, nein, natürlich kann man hier nicht suchen drinne. Open SSH-Server,
aha. Da ist es. Hat das jetzt installiert? Warum kann man hier eigentlich nicht drinnen,
Moment, ist der Open SSH-Client. Add Feature. Moment. Hä? Doch, gerade gemacht. Open SSH-Server.
Der installiert das nicht. Warum installiert der das nicht? Alter Microsoft, please, warum
sind die Sachen so unglaublich beschissen unter Windows? Ok, Max, bitte über den Server.
Alles klar. Ist das Server-Manager das hier? Moment, ist das, meinst, wo ist das überhaupt
hin? Du meinst das hier, oder? Server-Manager. Ok, dann, dann schieß los. Wo geht das jetzt?
Local Server, Remote Management. Oben rechts, Manage. Kripplistner. Und dann Add Roles and
Features? Ich find's aber geil, dass das hier drüber nicht funktioniert, ne? Obwohl
das Microsoft, ach, kommt mal. Was macht der da? Was macht der da gerade?
Das ist ziemlich langsam, ne? Ok. Ach, ihr meint die Windows-Updates würden nicht funktionieren
jetzt? Pending Restart. Soll ich wirklich jetzt rebooten dafür? Ok, also was müsst ihr
jetzt hier machen? Add Server Selection before you begin. Ok, next. Role. Ok, was? Ach, hier
kann man den Server auswählen, das ist einfach nur... So, und da kann man jetzt bestimmt
SSH irgendwo auswählen oder auch nicht. Features. Ah, SSH, hier. SSH Server. Was? Nicht SMTP.
Äh, meint. Komm ich auf SMTP? SSH? Null. Äh, gibt's nicht? Äh, ja. Aber ich kann
ein Interia-Client installieren. Fuck Server, Alter. Ah, ok, also das mit SSH Server installieren
scheint nicht so zu tun. Ähm, ich muss jetzt wohl erstmal warten bis Windows-Updates fertig
sind. Eventuell das Open SSH. Oh, Big Brain Chat. Big Brain. Guck mal mal. Ja, ja, ja.
Hallo? Windows? Windows? Will Gates guckt gerade persönlich nach. Local Host Timeout?
Ok, wait. Ok, vielleicht liegt es wirklich an Windows-Updates, dass der rumspackt. Ok,
Leute, Leute, ich sag euch mal was. Ich sag euch mal was. Es ist Windows. Das dürfen wir
nicht vergessen. Restart. Jaja. Danach geht das. Danach geht das. Reboot. Reboot hilft
bestimmt. Guck mal, wer Rebooted hat. Getting Windows ready. Don't turn your computer off.
Alles klar. Mir ist es absolut unbegreiflich, wie man sowas wirklich verwenden kann. Das
versteht es nicht. Wir machen docker. Gleich haben wir docker drauf. Ja. Gleich haben wir
docker drauf. Das wird jetzt lange. Warum? Warum braucht der 30 Stunden dafür? Ich hab
doch gar nichts gemacht. Was gettet er da eigentlich ready? Oh. Ach, Updates. Ok, Big
Update. Alles klar. Danach installieren wir Hyper-V. Und machen eine VM in der VM. Wir
machen da eine Linux-VM in der Windows-VM. Wisst ihr, und ich denke immer, dass es schon
eine Zumutung ist, wenn ich mal ein Ubuntu oder ein Debian oder ein Ratchet oder sonst
etwas machen muss und der da 10 Minuten rumröten. Wobei 10 Minuten ist viel zu lang. 5 Minuten.
Ach guck mal, er startet. Excellent. Trusted Installer. Aha, G-Bated. You got G-Bated.
Man dachte er ist fertig. Er war gar nicht fertig. Jetzt haben wir's. Jetzt haben wir's
Leute. Jetzt gehen wir wieder an unseren Remote Desktop. Yes, don't ask me again. Aha, da
sind wir wieder Leute. Da sind wir wieder. Das ging tatsächlich relativ schnell. Moment,
wir haben, wir haben. Was ist das? Was ist hier los? Oh. Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Warum ist das jetzt alles rot? Ich hab doch gar nichts gemacht. Ich hab, ich hab doch
legit nichts gemacht. Oh guck mal, es geht weg. Es geht weg. Es geht langsam weg. Habt
ihr das gesehen? Jetzt sind es nur noch 5. Ah, delayed start, ok. Stand ich auch dahinter,
delayed start. Ok, also können wir das ignorieren. Was macht denn eigentlich unsere SSH Server
denn? Apps? Features? Warum kann man hier eigentlich nicht drinne suchen? Ok, es scheint
installiert zu sein. Scheint installiert zu sein. Open SSH Server. Poggers. Ok, gleich
mal gucken, ob es funktioniert. Nein, nein, nein, nicht dahin. Geh weg. Was? Man muss
bestimmt den Service starten noch. Ok, Service. SSH. Nee, Open SSH. Open SSH Server, der ist
nämlich nicht gestartet. Starten. Jetzt aber. Jetzt aber. Bam. Housekey Verification failed.
Ja, den Scheiß können wir immer wieder komplett löschen. So, yes. Nein, Administrator. Administrator.
Root ist so einfach zu tippen, ne? Kannst du mal PowerShell Remote probieren? Ja, probier
mal, probier mal gleich aus. Fingerprint. Oh, MonkaS. 123456, underscore A. Da sind
wir. Leute. Exzellent. Wir sind Remote über SSH auf ne Windows Server und haben ne CMD
offen. Und das ist also Batchgedöns. Das ist PowerShell. PowerShell. Komm, man kann sogar
ne PowerShell starten. Huge Poggers. Also, das geht ja nicht unter, unter Windows. Ah,
man kann sogar ne PowerShell starten. Kann man auch SSHX Forwarding machen? Hehehe, nee,
das ist zu schön. Moment, startet er das jetzt auf meinem? Wartet mal kurz, Leute. Ok, die
haben keinen Bock. Startet er das jetzt? Wenn ich das jetzt hier starte in der PowerShell,
startet er das jetzt auf meinem Desktop? Nee, der macht einfach gar nix. Alles klar. Was
auch immer. Äh, wie kommt man hier raus? Exit. NapGuaMoase. Exit. Ok, machen wir mal
SSH GUI Weiterleitung. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Moment, kann man Keys kopieren? SSH CopyCopyID. Nein,
das wär auch zu einfach, wenn das funktioniert. Server Manager. Nee, ok, also das wär auch
zu abgedreht, wenn X Forwarding funktionieren würde. Äh, ja, LS ist ein Alias in PowerShell.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, wo sie den Linux Leuten entgegen kommen wollten, was sie in
PowerShell eingebaut haben. Ok, also das, das, das funktioniert schonmal. Bin ich, ich bin
ja zum Teil begeistert. So, wie macht man den Server Manager wieder auf, wenn man zugemacht
hat? Da war er. VGET ist auch ein Alias. Sag mal, wie lang brauchen eigentlich die Services,
bis die starten? Jetzt mal ehrlich, das dauert ja 10 Minuten, bis der Kram auf ist. Was sagst
du, VGET gibt's? PowerShell. Moment, was ist das? Oh, das kenn ich. Das ist diese komische
PowerShell IDE, die dabei ist. Gehst sofort. PowerShell. VGET, kommt ein Problem aus. VGET
ist ein Alias auf den Internet Explorer.
Was, was soll ich davon halten jetzt?
Los. Gibt's einen CURL? Gibt's auch einen CURL? Das ist ein fucking Internet Explorer
Link. Das ist so kaputt. Ok, die Services sind immer noch nicht gestartet. Alles klar,
ok, weiter, weiter im Text. Also, es ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht. Wir haben's ja schon
mal geschafft. Jetzt ist es hart Zugang zu installieren. Mit kann ich zwar nichts anfangen,
aber... Ach Moment, Parrot Life. Gute Idee. Nein, das geht nicht. Das geht nicht. CURL
Mache mal ADD anstatt CLOSE, ok. Ich ADD jetzt einfach alles. Ich muss das gerade doppelt
ADDen. Was du bisher verpasst hast, viele merkwürdige Windows Sachen. Also, by the way, wer sich
fragt, wie die Seite aussehen sollte. Eigentlich sollte die Seite so aussehen. Mit einem normalen
CURL funktioniert das ohne Probleme. Aber das Beste ist ja immer noch... Ah ne, das hab
ich jetzt hier nicht gestartet. Du kannst doch den IE komplett rausnehmen. Ah ne, darf ruhig
so bleiben. Ok, der Kram, der mag nicht starten. Das ist wirklich... Ah, das ist stopped. Ok,
wenn es absichtlich stopped ist, dann muss es das doch auch nicht als rot anzeigen. Ok,
nächste. Wir ignorieren das jetzt. Ok, weiter im Text. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich
das jetzt ernsthaft machen will, weil ich hab mir aufgeschrieben, ich würde gerne
eine statische HTML-Seite hosten. Aber nachdem ich gesehen hab... Was das für ein riesen
Act ist, so einfache Dinge anzumachen. Wie würde ich eine statische HTML-Seite hosten?
Ok, add roles and features. Ich mach das mal als Windows-Noob, ja. Skip this page by default,
ja. Als Windows-Noob, der echt keine Ahnung davon hat. Also Windows... Ich suche... Ich
würde jetzt nach Web-Server suchen. Ich würde jetzt nach Web-Server suchen. Web-Server.
Add features. Next. Äh, brauch ich da alles net? Talent client, das macht mich immer
noch fertig, dass es ein eigenes Feature ist unter Windows. Next. Naja, next. Was will
er von mir? Was, dritte von unten? Wireless... Der WLAN-Service. Ok, next. FreshBK, was denn?
Drei Minuten macht doch nix, drei Minuten geht doch schnell. Oder meinst du damit, es
dauert nicht lang. Äh, static, static content. Ja, genau das brauch ich, static content.
Next. Install. So. Also, er installt jetzt auf Nabukumamasa, sei. Alles klar. Easy.
Also für mich als Linux-Mann ist das eher... Es ist auf eine gewisse Art und Weise unterhaltsam,
aber auch nur vor dem Hintergrund, dass ich weiß, ich muss es nie verwenden. Weil wenn
ich wüsste, ich müsste das verwenden, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich eher verzweifeln
da dran. Ok, Klaus. Jetzt hab ich nen Web-Server installiert. Guck mal, man kann das sogar
da drüber verwalten, das ist ja richtig big brain. So, und jetzt irgendwo ne statische
HTML-Seite reinlegen. Wo ist denn hier so der... Der www-Root quasi, wo ist denn das
hier? Nickteaming, ist das sowas wie Bonding? Noch nie nen Arbeitgeberwechsel in Betracht
gezogen. Ja doch, wenn ich Windows-Server machen müsste, dann schon. IES-Manager, ist
das doch hier der IES? Nee. Oben rechts Tool? Ah, hier der Internet Information Services
Manager. Ah, Big Brain Tool. Sieht wahrscheinlich seit Windows 2003 genauso aus. So. Also das
heißt, wenn ich jetzt auf den Server gehe, hab ich dann schon ne Seite? Äh, was war's?
130, 230, 130, ne? Oah, Porgers. Es ist schonmal ne Seite, das ist doch schonmal gut. 2003
war noch etwas eckiger. Wie willst du das von dir entscheiden können, wenn du noch nie
mit Windows gearbeitet hast? Ich hab genug mit Windows gearbeitet, dass ich weiß, ich
will damit nichts zu tun haben. Zumindest nicht live, ja? Jetzt hier ein bisschen mit
rumspielen ist ja eigentlich ganz nett, aber nee, nee, nee, nee. Geh mal bloß fort. Jedesmal,
wenn ich mit Windows was machen muss, krieg ich absolut Anfälle, wo Sachen versteckt
werden. Ich mein, allein schon die glorreiche Idee von Microsoft, dass dieses komische Feature
hinzufügen Telnet kleint. Ich mein, ganz im Ernst, wer hat sich das hier überlegt?
Warum gibt's hier keine Suche drin und solche Sachen? Warum? Das ist alles total, total
zusammengestückelt irgendwie. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das unter Linux die Usability,
dass Usability mecker ist oder so. Da gibt's auch genug viel Scheiß, ja? Keine Frage.
Aber es fühlt sich alles nicht so hakelig an. So, okay, ich will eine statische HTML-Seite
anzeigen. Wie mach ich das? Start-Seite, die Start-Seite ist hier. New Site. Wo ist
mein www-Root? Wo muss ich eine statische Seite hinlegen? Unten umschalten auf Content.
Ah, ah, guck mal da. Ah, Big Brain. Add Website. Okay, wir machen jetzt mal eine ganz, ganz
tolle, äh, statische Website. Dann gehen wir mal irgendwo hin. Ahnung. C. Enet-Pupp,
da rein? Oh, guck mal, wir haben einen richtig echten www-Root. Krasser Shit. Alter. Das
heißt ja noch www-Root. Okay. Poggers.html. Ähm, hallo. Komm, egal. So, kann ich da jetzt
direkt drauf? Poggers.html. Nein. Ach, stimmt. Oh, es ist ja Windows. Ja, ja. Es schmerzt,
es schmerzt. Okay, View. Dateierweiterung. File-Extension. Yes. Boah. Okay, wir haben
es geschafft. Web-Server am Start. Wahnsinn. Die Seite sieht ja auch aus. Sehr gut. Sehr
gut. So. Ähm. Okay, und jetzt kommen die, jetzt kommen die schwierigen Sachen. Also
ich hab mir aufgeschrieben Remote Access. Dann guck mal, ob SSH installieren kann. Äh,
ob man einen Web-Server installiert kriegt mit einer statischen HTML-Seite. Dann ob
es so was wie einen Paket-Manager gibt, aber sowas wie einen Paket-Manager gibt es nicht.
Es gibt hier dieses Rolls- und Features-Update-Gedöns, aber es hat ja mit dem Paket-Manager nichts
zu tun. So, und jetzt wollen wir mal Docker installieren. Da bin ich jetzt mal wirklich
sehr gespannt drauf. Docker unter Windows ist ja Hyper-V. Zumindest war es das am Anfang.
Ob das immer noch so ist. Deswegen müssen wir das glaube ich hier mal stoppen, den Server
anhalten und Virtualisierung einschalten, dass das klappt. Äh, bin ich jetzt auch vom Server
drauf? Shutdown. Unplanned. Okay. Docker unter Windows ist cute. Sicher. Docker, ah, Windows-Container
laufen ohne Hyper-V, aber eben nur Windows-Programm. Okay, verstehe. Aber man kann doch, man kann
doch auch Docker-Container machen mit Linux-Programm, oder? Und dann ist es ein Hyper-V-Container.
Äh, Hyper-V-VM. Also, Options. Wo ging das jetzt nochmal? CPU. Virtualize. Das da. Power
on. Paket-Manager-Install-Package. Ja, aber da kann ich nicht einfach sowas wie, sagen
wir mal, Firefox. Nee, na gut, Firefox ist ein doofes Brand. Nginx installieren oder
sowas? Echt? Das probieren wir mal aus jetzt gleich. So, immer wieder RDP drauf. Das liest
sich so als wärs PowerShell, hä? Liest sich ein bisschen so als wärs PowerShell. Was?
Find-Package. Find-Package. Find-Package. Okay, Nginx. Oh, ich kann mal net, ich glaub,
so schreibt man. Was? Nougat is not installed. Yes, mach einfach. Yes. Oh. WTF? Ah, der findet's
nicht. Okay, das ist dann bloß für Windows eigene Geschichten. Das ist nix mit, äh,
das ist nix für normale Software. Nee, nee, was kann man da so zum Beispiel installieren?
Docker? Ah. Ah nee, Find-Package. Das sind PowerShell Extensions, hä? Visual Studio,
mal Visual, äh, Visual. Keine Ahnung, Code. Was auch immer. Okay, was mach ich? Windows
Server Host, Windows Server Container. Excellent. Oh. Okay. Äh, da brauch ich nen Guide zu.
Install Docker Windows 2019. Ah. Ah, geht ja schon gut los. Null. Äh. Äh, ist es Server?
Ah. Install Docker und Windows 10, nee. Okay, ich muss die Windows 10 Anleitung wahrscheinlich
machen. Kann man das nicht über den Server Manager machen? Irgendjemand hat auch gerade
geschrieben, man muss. Irgendjemand hat auch gerade geschrieben, man muss irgendwo auf
Windows Server Host oder so. Windows Server Host, Windows Server Container. Wo, wo, wo,
wo steht das? Peaches. Okay, bla, bla, bla, Hyper-V, Hyper-V. Install mir mal ne Runde
Hyper-V. Kann ich schaden. Nee, nee, keine Windows, ich will, ich will richtig echte
Videos ausprobieren, wie gut das funktioniert. Okay, Containers. Ah, Windows Server Containers.
Switches, Switches. Äh. Okay, was auch immer. Ähm, dann installieren wir jetzt mal wirklich
Docker, da stand doch hier irgendwo, Docker, Windows. Get Docker Desktop für Windows Server,
nee Server. Install Docker Enterprise Engine. Ich will nicht die Enterprise Engine, ich
will einfach Install Docker Windows 2019. Hier, Six-Eyed, was auch immer. Nicht Six-Eyed,
Five-Headed. Connection, okay, also was? Install Windows Feature Containers, Setup, Install
Docker und Windows, Install Module, Docker, MS, ja wer, alles in der Welt kommt dann da
rein. Meint das den Windows Container? Äh, what the fuck. Boah ey, das überfordert
mein Brain gerade. Das überfordert mein Brain. Linux. Ja, die Docker für Windows Installer
hab ich ja schon gefunden, aber da steht doch nix von Server. Ich rat mir das jetzt einfach
Windows typisch von der Docker-Webseite runter. Install Docker Windows 2019, Lul. Zack. What
the fuck? Install Docker und Windows. Hyper-V and Container Features, okay, das müssen
wir noch hinzufügen. Add Roles, also Hyper-V, add, ja mach und Containers, und Containers,
next, naja, next, was auch immer, next, alles klar, next, mach weiter, install. So und eh
machen wir noch PowerShell auf, da hab ich gesagt Find Package, da konnte ich Docker
suchen. So und das macht jetzt was, muss ich das noch mal suchen, dass er das breiter
schreibt. This model helps with development, it detects, was soll man das installieren?
Aber kann man damit nicht angeblich auch Linux-Software ausführen und dass er das dann der Hyper-V
Vm macht, probieren wir jetzt aus. Ich warte jetzt bis der Kram installiert ist, was bringt
hier Docker, das weiß ich noch nicht, was das unter Windows bringt. Restart, ach ja,
exellent, Windows Restart, alles klar. Restart pending, okay, ja wir restarten. Install Package
Docker, natürlich lese ich den Chat, aber der Chat schreibt laufend irgendwas anderes,
mal so, mal so, ich kann ja nicht so schwer sein. Install module, Docker Provider install,
probier mal gleich aus. Also das hier mag schon mal nicht, vielleicht weil er am Neustart
hängt oder es zeigt kein Progress an. Was? Okay ich starte erstmal neu, man muss ja mal
zwischendurch neu starten, dass es funktioniert. Okay, ist er wieder da? Warte mal, ach nee,
der Chat, ah Updates, wie konnte ich das vergessen, dass der erst zwei Stunden immer wieder neue
Updates installieren muss. Was ist denn der intelligent, intelligent background, was auch
immer Service? So, da ist er wieder. Moment, nein, nein, ah, hab ich doppelt aufgemacht,
einmal da, einmal da, ja ja, Disconnect. Background Intelligent Transfer Service, das klingt sehr
big brain. Okay, PowerShell, PowerShell, Install, Package, Docker. Packages, Trust, yes. War das
ich eben schon größer gemacht und eben schon viel größer eingestellt oder? Aha, hat er
das jetzt installiert? Docker, nein. Okay, dann mach ich jetzt mal das, was der Kellmore
geschrieben hat. Install, okay, also Install, Module, Docker, Provider, yes, yes, yes, yes,
Docker, what? Und dann was? Docker, ich will kein Brave View, ich will einfach, dass es,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was das treibt, yes, Docker, ah, hoho, guck mal da, krass. Wie
ist die Enterprise Experience so unglaublich? Wahnsinn, ganz toll, Docker, who am I, Container,
genau, den starten wir jetzt mal. Was? Ja, das ist ja auch kein Windows, kein Windows
Docker. Ja, ich weiß, dass es Docker LS ist. Kann man keine Linux Dockers ausführen? Okay,
das geht anscheinend nicht. Run Linux Docker Windows. Ich mein, man kann WSL installieren
hier. Die haben hier grandiose, to run Linux. Okay. Run Hello World, okay, schauen wir mal,
ob das funktioniert. Also Kellmore, wenn man sowas braucht, wäre ja echt armselig. Okay,
das hat funktioniert. Ja, bla, bla, Explore Application, bla, bla, bla. Linux. Ach hier,
Resource Tab. Aha, das war auch die Windows Version von Hello World, garantiert. Mein
Gott ist der Scheiß kompliziert, ey. Docker Settings Dialog. Hab ich jetzt Docker Settings
Dialog? Boah, ich kriege Anfälle. Okay, ich mache jetzt das, was der Kellmore sagt, was
aber halt echt lächerlich wäre, wenn das nur so funktioniert. Was zum? Es ist Windows,
was erwartest du? Ja, ja wenig. So, jetzt ist die Frage, ob es funktioniert. Extracting,
Hausechamp. Ja, funktioniert. Es läuft, Leute, es läuft.
Stopp. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier auf 5, Port, Moment, Port 55019 gehe. 1, 9. Oh,
ups. Fast. Who am I? Wir haben den Linux-Docker-Container laufen auf Windows. Okay, das ging sogar,
das ging halbwegs. Also, das habe ich mir schlimmer vorgestellt, wobei das Setting
ist immer noch sehr merkwürdig. Willst du jetzt noch mal Docker vor Windows? Ich dachte
ja eigentlich, dass man das so machen kann, ohne über eine Webseite Installer klicken
zu müssen. Docker vor Windows. Install. Dann Docker Desktop. Ja, GIF. Ja, ich habe
GIF. Stable. Das müsste die Enterprise-Passion sein. Okay, das ist mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
egal. Kann man das sogar parallel laufen lassen? Docker Desktop ist nur für Dev-Zwecke. Ja,
juckt mich nicht. Wenn ich wirklich, ich will es einfach nochmal auspringen, wenn ich wirklich
Linux-Docker-Anwendung live laufen lassen will, dann mache ich das wahrscheinlich eh
nicht auf dem Windows-Docker. Sondern ganz stinknormal auf der Linux-Kiste, wie ich es
normalerweise eh machen würde. Aber das ging relativ gut, muss man echt sagen. Hat man
wieder gesehen, die ganzen Subs haben sich gelohnt, weil es ist wieder excellent Big
Ten. Chat. Wie weit bist du ja, Docker unter Windows-Schalt zu funktionieren? QEMU-Image.
Bugsnack. Die finden sich in ihrem Installer auch geil, oder? Wie das hier unten ausfaded.
Die feiern sich da richtig. Danach musst du Windows neu starten. Höchstwahrscheinlich.
Die IHK hat einfach euer Ergebnis der Abschlussprüfung geliegt am Samstag. Wie liegt denn die IHK
auf die Abschlussprüfungsergebnisse? Macht der da? Wie viel Festplattenplatz verbraucht
der Kram eigentlich gerade? Geht eigentlich? Nur 20G? Lockout? Okay. Wenn Docker das sagt.
Docker Info, ja, kann ich machen. Nee, das läuft doch jetzt beides, oder? Oder hat sich
das eine jetzt Docker Info. Das ist die Enterprise hier. Das ist Enterprise. Und das hier ist
Desktop. Wie auch immer, der das jetzt unterscheidet. Docker. Ah ja. Oh, was? Ich hab 4Gigabyte
drin. Wollt ihr mich veräppeln? What? Jetzt startet er gar nicht mehr, oder was?
Okay, jetzt hat er keinen Bock mehr. Docker Desktop Excel, weg damit. Bam. Dann startet
er wieder. Aha. Ach, da ist es. Da ist es. Aha. Ist er einfach einmal beenden und wieder
starten, dann geht's. So. Da ist es. Docker is starting. Kubernetes. Nicht genug Sp- Das
Ding hat 4Gigabyte. 4Gigabyte. Das muss doch reichen um... Okay. 4Gigabyte ist doch nix.
Ja, das stimmt. Für Windows reicht das nicht. Okay, wir machen das. Ich hab ja genug RAM.
Da kriegt er jetzt einfach mehr RAM. Ich hab ja genug. Ich hab, wie viel hab ich eigentlich
mittlerweile? 16 oder 32? 16, ne? Ich hab 16. Habe ich zu... Ey, ich hab 32. Okay, da
kann der Stall noch eine ganze Ecke mehr kriegen. Easy. Kein Problem. Ja. Flop. Perfekt. Mehr
RAM. Mehr RAM. Man kann nie genug RAM haben. Ich hab extra 32 GB, damit ich fürs nächste
Windows Update gerüstet bin. Ja, Captain Peng, das nachvollziehbar, ja. Pongas. Mal gucken,
ob es jetzt funktioniert. Kann man den Server Manager irgendwie ausschalten? Dass der nicht
am Anfang mal aufploppt? Review? Hide welcome? Oh, Docker startet. Habt ihr gesehen, da ist
er. Da läuft er. Docker is starting. Mal gucken, ob der RAM jetzt reicht. Wow. Der frisst
schon ordentlich RAM. Der ist da schon nicht genügend, sondern nicht genügsam. Ja, haben
wir. So. Und nun? Open Power Stall and start hacking with Docker or Compose. Excellent.
Also. Start. Oh, die haben da sogar eine Power-Spitze, aber hier. Git clone getting started.
Okay, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es natürlich nicht standardmäßig. Nein. Kein. Ah. Kein
Internet Explorer. Jetzt muss ich neu anmachen. Ja, Windows. Ja, wunderbar, mach. Next. Alles
auf dem Windows. Darf man drauf klatschen, was geht? Und desktop. Ja, schadet nichts.
Get bashed hier. Get GUI hier. Nein, keine Windows Explorer. Next. Was? Oh. Wim ist default.
Wie modern? Was? Wer ertreist sich hier zu sagen Wim wäre nicht modern? Was ist hier
los? Als wäre Wim nicht modern, Leute. Also ich glaube, es geht los hier. Was wird gemacht?
Docker und Windows installiert, weil es geht. Use git from git bash only. Ah ja, mach weiter,
weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter. Nanowimp. Ich habe, ich habe halber wie schon installiert.
Und ich kriege Anfälle beim bei der Windows Bedienung wieder. Lounge git bash. Keck weh.
Font rendering allererste Sahne. Okay, jetzt klonen wir das. Bestimmt, weil es dort nicht
immer ein Wireman drinne ist. Wie mache ich jetzt die Shell wieder auf? Wie mach ich das?
Oh, wie mach ich das? Wie? Nee, ich hab es Patrick, ich hab das in der VM. Ich würde
es im Leben nicht auf desktop installieren. Dashboard. Ah, da, da. Und jetzt? Und jetzt
kriege ich kein PowerShell mehr. Ach gut. PowerShell. So brauche ich dieses GUI Ding
hier eigentlich? Kann ich noch mal das Getting Started aufrufen? Ach, hier switch to Windows
Container Switch. Docker Info. Ist immer noch Enterprise Engine. Ja. Hier kann man aussehen,
was man haben will. Command Line. Wie kann man hier eine Command Line jetzt aufmachen?
Ach, das ist mir alles zu kompliziert. Es funktioniert zumindest. Ich konnte in Hallo
Welt Container starten. Das reicht. Okay, als nächstes Hyper-V. Hyper-V Manager. Dann
gucken wir mal, wie das funktioniert. Hab ich noch nie gemacht was mit. Hyper-V. Wie installiert
man in Hyper-V eine VM? Hyper-V. Docker Desktop VM. Nee, nee, das wollen wir nicht. Wir wollen
eine neue VM. New. Virtual Machine. Next. Ubuntu. Mal gucken, ob wir das installiert
kriegen. Da bin ich echt mal gespannt jetzt. So, Name. Ubuntu. Generation. Generation 1.
1.024 reicht. No Network. Not Excellent. Size 20G reicht. Next. Finish. So, und jetzt
Ubuntu Minimal Download. The Network Installer. Ja, wunderbar. BitTorrent erinnert mich irgendwie
ein bisschen an. Hat aber miteinander nichts zu tun. Okay, scheint komplizierter zu sein.
Ubuntu Server Download. Bin einfach nur gucken, ob es funktioniert. Ich will das gar nicht
großartig installieren. Wir gucken, ob es startet und anfängt zu installieren. Das reicht
mir schon. Es wird eh nicht schnell funktionieren, weil das nestet virtualisiert. Das nestet
virtualisiert immer krotten lahm. So. Wie startet man das jetzt? Einfach Doppelklicken.
Connect. Ah, da ist es. Start. Ja, sehr gut. Oh Mist, wie komme ich hier wieder raus?
Was ist das Escape für Hyper-V? Ctrl Alt Entfernen. Moment, da ist ein Remote Desktop
drüber. Oh, das verwirrt mich jetzt, aber das sieht exakt genauso aus. Kann man das
verschieben? Ein bisschen. Ein bisschen verschieben kann man das. Perfekt. So, Media, DVD, Insert
und Disc. Ubuntu. Ist der Download fertig? Ja. Ist jetzt eingelegt. Okay. Äh, verstanden.
Aha. Poggers. Äh. Normalerweise müsste ich da jetzt eigentlich was auswählen können.
Okay, aber es sieht so aus, als startet er. Das ist schon mal gut. Yep. Dass die Installation
lahm wie Sau ist, ist okay. Nested Virtualisierung juckt nicht, ja. Als nächstes, ähm, ich
habe noch eine Sache draufstehen. Mal WSL installieren. Gucken wir mal WSL unter Windows Server installiert.
WSL Windows Server. Windows Server 2019. Äh, wir können das gleich mal unter 2. Bin, was?
Good Server Preview. Nee. How to install WSL 2 on Windows Server. How to install WSL 2
on Windows Server. Nein, nein, kein Insider-Bild. Official. Das ist mittlerweile raus. Ja. Äh,
WSL. Gibt es eigentlich unter Windows Server auch den Windows Store? Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Mach die VM. Tatsächlich, guck mal da. Die Ubuntu VM läuft. Die PowerShell. WSL ist nur
für Windows 2. Achso. Ah. Oder? Ubuntu Server läuft. Waren wir da aus. How to install WSL 2. Steht aber doch da.
Okay, man braucht ein Preview-Bild. Das ist natürlich doof. Das haben wir nicht. Achso,
man muss sie noch ausschalten. Turn off. Ja, okay. Das können wir machen. PowerShell, zack,
enable feature. Wisst ihr, was ich sehr, was ich sehr, what? Das war einfach weg.
Es kann nicht mehr auskommen ohne Restart. Deswegen war GitHub heute down, ja. Das kann
ich mir richtig vorstellen. GitHub. Docker. Äh, nicht Docker. WSL installiert, zack. Loadbalancer
tot. Obwohl ich mich sehr wundern würde, wenn GitHub Windows Loadbalancer verwendet.
Okay, das haben wir schon installiert. Ein GitHub läuft höchstwahrscheinlich nicht auf
Windows. GitHub war mal am Anfang eine Hubi-on-Rails-Anwendung. Wow. Was macht der Typ da? Kann ich jetzt
WSL eingeben? Der WSL-Store, ich soll den WSL-Store visiten, steht da. Moment, warum
lädt er den Ubuntu ISO noch mal runter? Kann das mal weggehen? Das nervt mich. Geh weg,
jetzt. Geh weg. Hallo? Die Seite gibt's nicht. Die Seite gibt's nicht mehr. Die ist einfach
weg. Wie installier ich denn jetzt WSL? Die Seite gibt's nicht mehr. Was soll ich heute
am Start? Ich probiere mal das neuste Windows Server aus, um mich ein bisschen wieder darin
zu bestätigen, dass ich es nicht verwenden will. Geht das unter meinem Host? Ach, das
will den Store aufmachen. Den Store gibt's natürlich unter Server nicht. Ja, perfekt
Microsoft. Und jetzt? Ach, deswegen macht er diesen Krempel hier. Deswegen macht er
diesen Krempel hier, weil das sonst nicht geht. Und nun? Install manual. Aha. Ab X,
das kann man nicht installieren. Ich hab keinen Windows-Store drauf. Das geht nicht. Oder?
Nee, das wird nicht funktionieren. Install on server. Excellent. Chat, big brain. Darf
nicht kopieren. Jetzt. Ja, das hatten wir doch gerade schon. Extrahieren eines Power...
Whoa, whoa, what? Weil ab X kann ich nicht öffnen. Wir lassen ihn hier erstmal downloaden.
Kann ja nicht mal lange dauern. Und dann einfach starten. Braucht ganz schön lang. Andi erstmal
entpacken, danach entpacken, expand, big brain. Der braucht für den Download ganz schön
lang. Über den Browser ging das viel schneller. Versuche in der PowerShell add app X package.
Das geht bestimmt nicht. Add. App. Nee. App. App. X. Oh, doch. Downloads. Nee. U-Boot-to.
Oh, jetzt wird es aber hier richtig advanced über die PowerShell. PowerShell-Magic. Und
jetzt hat es es jetzt gemacht. Da ist es. Da ist es. Tatsächlich. Und der ist immer noch
am runterladen. Lull. Abbrechen. Rm. U-Boot-to. Zip. Bäm. Hat funktioniert. Ich glaube es
nicht. Ja, stimmt. Candy Crush brauchen wir wirklich nicht. Ist aber cool, dass man das
zumindest über die PowerShell machen kann. Also ich muss sagen, PowerShell ist noch das
erträglichste an ganz Windows. Sieht Windows Server wie Windows 10 aus? Ja. Mehr oder weniger.
Kann man Candy Crush installieren? FeelsBadMan. New username. Pog. Panzverband 256. Wenigstens
lässt mich das 123456 als Passwort verwenden. Und da sind wir. WSL am Start. So, mal gucken,
ob WSL 2 läuft. Das geht wahrscheinlich nicht. Nein. Nein. Nein, das ist noch das alte WSL.
Das gibt es noch nicht für Windows Server. Was kann man mit Windows Server machen? Der
fragt mich nicht. Er fragt mich was leichteres. Die Frage ist, sollte man damit was machen?
Und ich tendiere eher zu nein. Also was man damit schön machen kann, ist irgendwelche
Windows Clients managen. Von Windows Software Installationen bis Active Directory Gedöns,
wenn man sich das wirklich geben will. Aber ich glaube freiwillig macht das keiner. Wenn
es nicht unbedingt sein muss. Ich finde ja meinen Random Rechner Namen immer noch ziemlich
gut. Winn, Napgur, Mamase. Klingt irgendwie ein bisschen nach Zulul. Warum so ein Windows
Hate? Das ist kein Windows Hate. Das ist einfach die Realität. Change my mind. Minecraft Server
aus. Nein, nein, nein. Ich bin fertig mit allem was ich machen wollte in Windows. Ich
bin durch. Also, es ist noch genauso schlimm, wie ich das in Erinnerung hatte. Ja, ich habe
keine Ahnung davon. Das stimmt. Ist das jetzt eine Hyper-VVM? Nein, das ist keine Hyper-VVM.
Das hier ist eine Hyper-VVM. Das, die Ubuntu-Kiste, ist eine Hyper-VVM. Ja. Sind das so Server
wie CS Server? Was? Nee, CS Server kannst du in der Linux laufen lassen. Das würde
dich im Leben nicht unter Windows laufen lassen. Im Prinzip ist Windows Server nichts anderes
wie ein stabileres Windows 10 mit ein bisschen weniger Frontend Funktionen und dafür ein
paar eingebauten Services, so wie ein Web-Server und sowas. Hat Hyper-V inzwischen das Snapshot-Feature?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich verwende Hyper-V normalerweise nicht. Checkpoint, ja, guck
mal. Also, von dem ganzen Crap, den wir hier haben, hat Hyper-V tatsächlich noch den besten
Eindruck. Ach so, ja, das können wir noch machen. Aber ich glaube, das geht mit WSL
nicht. Können wir nach Mount, Mount C und dort alles löschen? Geht das? Geht anscheinend
nicht. Permission denied, sudo. Geht leider nicht. WSL als Admin ausführen, okay.
Und jetzt? Da haben wir Routepferden. CD, MNT. Nee. Wow. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Oh, oh, Skate
kaputt. Montags. Ich glaube, es hat sich selbst gelöscht, weil es hängt. Aber Windows kann
sich immer noch nicht löschen. Das darf ich nicht. Explorer. Oh, oh je. Montags, es ist
kaputt. Es ist abgekackt, Leute, es ist kaputt. Nee, doch nicht. Ha. Fast, das PC. Ja. Aha.
Okay, das geht gar nicht so schnell. Ich will es noch kaputt machen. Ich will es noch wenigstens
mal kaputt machen. Fuck. Ich darf das nicht löschen. Ich will mein Windows löschen.
Wie kriege ich mein Windows? Du musst Permissions auf dem Windows Ordner ändern, okay? Okay,
Windows. Wie macht man das? Advanced Sharing. Nee. Advanced. Nee. Security. Full Control.
Administrator. Allow. Administrator. All. Nee. Kann man Linux unter Linux löschen? Klar.
Was? Ich sollte mich als Owner setzen. Wüsste, wie das funktioniert. Würde ich das sogar
machen? Aha. Aber ich habe Modify. Ich habe Modify-Rechte. Full Control. Owner. Administrator.
All. Nee. Darf es nicht löschen? Ach so, Moment, habe ich das falsch gemacht? Change
Permissions. Aha. S. Nein. Windows weigert sich, sich selbst zu löschen. Das ist aber
nicht sehr nett von Windows, dass es das macht. Kann man, kann man den Explorer als Root starten?
Und Explorer. Okay, das ist kaputt. Aber ich, ah, ich habe eine Idee. Ich kann, ich kann
ein CMD als Root starten. Oder auch nicht. PowerShot als Root starten. Oh, ich glaube,
ich habe, ich glaube, ich habe es kaputt gemacht. Ich glaube, ich habe es kaputt gemacht. Es
geht nicht mehr. Es tut nichts mehr. Wir gucken jetzt mal, ob es einen Neustart überlebt.
Restart. Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob es den Neustart überlebt oder ob es jetzt RIP ist.
Gucken, ob es jetzt kaputt ist. Okay, noch starte das. Äh, ja, ja, alles gut, alles
gut. Ich will, ich will Windows noch irgendwie kaputt machen. Das kann auch nicht so schwer
sein. Früher hat sich Windows immer selbst kaputt gemacht. Jetzt will ich das mal selbst
machen. Oh, es geht wieder so halbwegs. Was sagt, okay, CMD, aber ich kann CMD, ich,
ah doch, ich kann CMD. Als Administrator. Also was sagt Google? Das machen wir jetzt.
Wir machen das jetzt CMD. Google sagt was? EMDR slash silent, silent, quiet, was auch
immer. Äh, C Doppelpunkt. Nein, das geht nicht. Wahnsinn. C Doppelpunkt Windows. Nein, krass.
Windows lässt sich nicht löschen. Was soll das hier? Piss dich also. Schon, schon interessant.
Ich dachte, es wäre einfacher, Windows mit Windows kaputt zu machen. System 32. Bäm.
Kannst du den Windows Ordner umbenennten? Das ist eine gute Frage. Kann man Windows
Ordner umbenennten? Wahrscheinlich auch nicht, ne? Nein, nein, ich habe auf Delete geklickt.
Kann ich Delete drücken? Rename. Es gibt, es gibt kein Rename. Ich verschiebe ihn einfach
nach Users. Okay Leute, ich bin nicht in der Lage, Windows kaputt zu machen. Ich krieg's
nicht in. Äh, okay Leute, das interessiert mich jetzt wieder jetzt. How to delete Windows
from Windows. Okay, der Patrick hat Big Brain Eintrag gefunden. Gucken wir uns gleich an,
wie das funktioniert. Erstmal ein Chrome, ein Chrome hab ich ja gelöscht. Okay, nee,
nein, muss ich hier aufmachen. Windows. Start as administrator. Was? Ich hab mein Chrome
gelöscht. Okay, weißt du was? Scheiß drauf. Windows will nicht, dass ich es kaputt mache.
Windows kann aber hiergegen überhaupt nichts machen. Get wrecked Windows. Keine Chance,
was dagegen zu machen. Open VM directory. VMs. Remove. Remove. Zack, weg ist es. Easy.
Nee, RMSF hat nicht funktioniert. Yes. Da, weg ist es Windows. Also ich muss sagen, es
ist noch genauso eklig, wie ich es mir vorgestellt hab. Ist nicht besser geworden. Was mich überzeugt
hat, war jetzt auf den ersten Blick Hyper-V. Das war echt nicht übel. Also es hat einfach
so funktioniert, wie es funktionieren sollte. Der Rest ist halt so extrem hakelig und eklig
in der Verwendung. Ah, ich weiß nicht. Nee, nee, nee. Ist das wirklich dein erster Windows?
Na ja, nein, ich hab schon immer mal wieder zwischendurch installiert. Aber wirklich,
ich kenne mich damit nicht aus. Und mittlerweile mache ich es ja auch so, wenn mich irgendwie
einer was fragt, was Windows Sachen angeht, so was weiß ich, wenn mich zum Beispiel eine
Freundin von meiner Mutter oder so sagt, ah, guck mal, der Max, der kennt schon mit Computerzeug
aus. Der kann mir doch bestimmt erzählen, wie ich keine Ahnung an meinen Drucker einrichte
oder so. Nein, mach ich nicht. Sag ich immer, ich hab keine Ahnung davon. Frage mich ja,
also Choose my name sagt, frage mich ja, ob Microsoft selber eher Windows Server oder
eher Linux Server nutzt. Das ist eine gute Frage. Auf was läuft zum Beispiel Microsoft.com?
Na, Microsoft.com wird wahrscheinlich echt Windows laufen. Microsoft.com wird wahrscheinlich
wirklich auf Windows laufen, kann ich mir vorstellen. Haben wir vielleicht irgendwie
die Chance, das rauszukriegen? Haben wir irgendwie die Chance, das rauszukriegen vielleicht?
Ne, warte, wo will ich hin, der Network? Ah,.net, es läuft auf.net. Aber die Plattform
sieht man nicht. Microsoft.com läuft auf ASP.net Core. Nmap konnte doch, Nmap OS Detection gab
es doch die Möglichkeit, das Nmap, das versucht, rauszubekommen. Wie ging das nochmal? OS scan,
OS guess. Genau. Okay, probieren wir mal aus. Nmap, Microsoft.com, Minus O war es. Oder
Minus Null. Ist groß O. Jaja, ist gut. Nein, nein, nicht Parrot.ly. Okay, scanen wir mal
mit Microsoft.com, easy, wenn man gleich blacklisted. Oh, stellts, stellts, scan. What, what, what,
what? Ah ja, no OS Matches, okay. Er hat keine Ahnung, was das für ein OS ist. Wie gesagt,
ich glaube ja, das ist ASP.net Core. Weil Kestrel, Kestrel ist der, ich hab's euch ja
hier gezeigt, Kestrel ist der ASP.net Core Web Server. Gucken wir mal, ob Google irgendwas
rausrückt, auf was sie laufen, aber wahrscheinlich eher nicht, ne. GWS, okay, das ist irgendwie
Google Magic Kram. Das geht über irgendeinen, ja, das geht garantiert auf irgendeinen Load
Balancer. Ja, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass auch vieles bei Microsoft mit Dealungs
läuft, weil Windows Server Kram willst du dir vielleicht für Client Geschichten geben,
aber wenn du einfach nur Dienste bereitstellen willst im Internet, gibt sich doch keiner
freiwillig Windows Server, warum sollte man das machen? Live.com, was ist Bing, Bing?
Oh, was lädt das denn alles nach? Microsoft, okay, Bing läuft auf IES, tatsächlich. Wenigstens
Bing. Und Xbox? Xbox? Ich mein, da könnte alles drinstehen, ne, gibt's keine Infos
zu. Da kann alles drinstehen, ist auch egal. Also ich gehe stark von aus, dass selbst,
dass Microsoft selbst auch viele Sachen auf Linux laufen hat. Alles andere würde mich
echt wundern. Ah ja. So, wir haben jetzt noch, wir haben jetzt noch ein bisschen Zeit. Oder
ich gehe jetzt auf und grinde noch ein bisschen Path of Exile, das könnte ich auch machen.
Ich gehe auf und grinde noch eine Runde Path of Exile, so war mal das. Ich hoffe euch hat's
trotzdem gefallen im Stream, wer noch nicht gefollowed ist, kann mir gern ein Follow da
lassen, bisschen Sellout muss sein. Könnt ihr euch auch mal auf Twitter vorbeigucken,
YouTube ist grad nicht so viel los. Und ich hoffe man sieht sich im nächsten Stream wieder,
morgen gleich, morgen wahrscheinlich ungefähr gleich Uhrzeit wieder am Start, denke ich
mal. Und wir sehen uns, bis dann, macht's gut, CU.